投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀,現在是臺北時間2026年9月22號禮拜二,早上8點31分。
大家早安,我是劉廷浩,每天早上開門前半小時,我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經,新聞時事變化。
困霸數錢啦,沒有股市這一次週一的上漲,納斯達克指數已經創下收盤的新高了。
那你要知道,最近原油價格雖然從高檔開始回落,美國公債殖利率也是稍微回落,
不過總體而言
其實整個高利率的環境
還有中東的地緣政治緊張局勢
並沒有因此而降溫
好那美國股市沒有在害怕的
昨天費城半導體指數甚至大漲了4%
Intel大漲了12%
AND漲幅有10%
市值也來到1兆美元了
Meta更是飆漲了11.4%
大家都在發力
其實美國現在原油
即便昨天是重疊了4.5%
每桶現在都還是有95塊
比過去幾個月都還是來得高
布蘭特原油昨天下跌3.4%
每桶到現在都還有一百塊
美國股市沒有在怕高利率的
其實美國股市現在最大的矛盾
就是指數的確表現還是相對不錯
但底下有很多股票沒有這麼好做
目前不到30%的標普白指數
是站在50日均線之上
這說明著市場的廣度
還是比較明顯惡化的
就是從均衡來看
它主要由少數的個股來帶動來向上攻
那的確如果是從投資人的心理情緒來看
沒有股市的情緒位階
也沒有想象中來得高
這一波的創高跟前幾個月的創高
很明顯感受到心理情緒不太一樣
前幾個月是追高
這幾周或者說這兩天
是莫名其妙又創下歷史新高了
那支撐指數的關鍵還是企業的獲利
因為標普500指數第二季的美股盈餘
年征服大概是51%
過去四季累積征服是26%
同時預估本益比也大概從前一波的23倍
現在大概已經下滑到19倍了
這大概是10年的平均值了
如果你只看後疫情時代
就是2020年以後
那其實現在本益比就不是特別高了
相對之下
我們看到美國股市在這種高強度的獲利拉伸以後
整體而言跟2000年的本益比周期來做比較
就沒有這麼離譜高了
何況正常來講
在2000年和08年的經驗以後
通常市場願意給予泡沫更高的本益比
就以前可能覺得20倍就很高了
現在一檔股票25倍30倍
勉強都可以接受
這就是對於未來市場有樂觀預期
所以給予你更高的評價
所以不管是從水平比較來看
還是從垂直比較來看
雖然指數是創新高了
但是就如同我們過去的利潤
即便現在納指創新高
它都還是低極期
就是這麼離譜
因為獲利上升的速度實在太快了
我們以前在聽友會
也曾經跟投資朋友針對不同指數
來看待他們的前瞻本益比
基本上要估前瞻很好估
以前要估未來一年
你就害怕會估錯了
為什麼
因為景氣變動太大
現在資本支出訂單都已經幾乎全滿了
你基本上已經開始摸透
比如說臺積電
明年的EPS要怎麼估
就是假設產能利用率
全部到100%可以有多少
因為訂單已經滿了
當然原油價格一跌
美國股市就開始上漲
川習會前
是否代表著市場正在重新壓住風險降溫呢
油價這一次已經連續5000下跌了
那美中談判現在又釋出了一點訊號
似乎雙方在AI的共同談判當中已經取得框架
那這一次能源價格的降溫
當然是美國股市第一波噴出的重要關鍵
但另外一方面
像美伊的外交接觸是否有可能出現可能性傳出力度
川普也表示可能在聯合國大會期間
和伊朗總統
裴澤斯基來會面
另外一方面
美軍也表示
荷姆治海峽目前的石油
和液化天然氣的運量
已經來到六個月的高點
那美中官員在川習會前
針對AI又針對貿易投資談判
給出正面評價以後
當然就可以進一步
改善市場的風險情緒
這感謝誰能陪我到3000的888
中秋節快樂
我們是直播
你不要覺得我們是錄播
我們每天都是直播
所以每天跟投資朋友分享
就是從這些時事當中去尋找出
我們是否能夠從這些波動當中
看到每一個點數如何組合到現在的
那現在市場上最重要的傳導鏈很清楚
油價影響到通膨
通膨又影響到殖利率
殖利率再來決定科技股的估值
你說不對啊
那整個油價和通膨情緒沒有緩解
怎麼會現在估值還在衝高呢
因為估值沒有衝高
為什麼
因為獲利在往上升
獲利往上升
股價被迫就一定要往上走
但是本益比並不會因此而飆高
就這麼簡單
所以現在的行情就是靠基本面的買盤
跌深了或者本益比往下掉了
那價值型投資者買盤就會因此而出現
緩步的推高
這叫做行情總在半信半疑中成長
好我們看一下沒有股市四大指數表現
道瓊上漲366.0.7%
所以52048點
其實道瓊還在半年線左右主體
他算是四大指數當中
現在表現最弱的
那之前下跌的時候他也是最強的嘛
所以這很好理解
防禦性資產
標普Y指數上漲114.1.49%
收在7764點
那已經占上所有均線了
那斯達克指數昨天創下歷史新高了
上漲599點
2.26%
收在27122點
那整個主體已經逐步完成
幾乎所有均線開始重新上彎
回到多頭格局
費辦的部分上漲511點
4.29%
收在12433點
從位階來看最低的應該是費半
但費半從低點彈幅也不小
那下方有一點W底的感覺陸續出現
雖然前幾天那樣算不算第三隻腳
那很多人都以第三隻腳自豪
但是這個行情來看
很明顯下方買盤之爭
是比上方突破率來的更強
看起來大家越越預示
三大指數四大指數能夠買的指數
好像也不是特別多了
所以從費半而言
還是對於部分人是有比較大的吸引力的
那我們必須承認
在整個2026年到現在為止
其實漲幅最亮麗的還是大宗資產
美國股市反而是進入到第二梯隊
26年以來
整體漲幅最為亮麗的是DBC
大宗資產是以47.3%的報酬
遙遙領先
再至美國的價值股20.9%
美國小型股是16.2%
納斯達克指數是17%
科團債15.2%
大型股12%
成熟市場和新市場分別是11和12%
那其實如果從債券資產和避險資產來看
它有兩個極端
現金仍然今年有2.6%的報酬
但美國總體債券是平均下跌1.3%
投資等級在下跌2%
長天期債券下跌3.9%
TIPS也下跌0.9%
所以今年債券市場還是不好
但也沒有到2022年這麼慘
因為23 24 25債券已經算是連續三年上漲了
然後在26年又重新回到下行軌道
回到2022年當時的下行數據
不過22年
那個時候的總體跌幅
都是跌三層四層起跳
今年你要說債券跌到哪裡去
勉強跟配息互相打消
如果持有直債的
更是沒有太大沖擊
當然跌最重的還是你比特幣
不過比特幣其實今年跌幅
已經算收斂很多了
為什麼
最近只跌了7.6%
比特幣在昨天跟美國股市一樣
大幅跳高
突破8.5萬美元了
這是1月底以來的水準最高
你要知道
利率都已經高成這樣了
比特幣還可以往上走
這說明要麼就高利率的情緒
已經提前price in
完全反應完了
要麼就是市場上的風險情緒
就是在不知不覺當中重新歸來
因為大家過去都騙比較保守
那現在反而有進一步的現金能夠湧入
從上週低點
這樣子彈幅已經彈了接近有16%了
以太幣也一度逼近到2750美元
那其他加密貨幣也同步走高
這一波反彈和全球風險資產的回溫是同步發生的
油價回落沒在支利率下降
但是呢下降所帶來的利多
是大於當時上升所帶來的利空
所以股價反而做突破了
那現在更進一步觀察的是
因為比特幣距離今年1月當時超過9.7萬的高點
還是有一段距離啊
那8.5萬美元附近
剛剛好是接近美國現貨比特幣ETF投資人的平均成本
就是在過去三年的平均成本
大家就卡在8萬5
所以這是一個很重要的多空的分界
就是很多人被套了兩年
被套了一年多
你要停損就趁現在了
看起來邏輯是這樣子
平均成本
那會不會造成一系列的停損賣壓呢
我倒認為不至於
有些人已經都忘記自己持有比特幣了
已經消失很久了
但可以從這樣的一個角度來看
如果連風險資產領頭像比特幣
都開始大幅的往上走
好那是否代表的情緒正在歸來呢
其實我們必須承認
現在說的行情還是跟AI聯動在一塊
只是它會尋找不同的硬體股
軟體股
資安股題材相互進行輪動
我們看在過去一週
美國散戶是一邊賣科技基金和多數各國
但是一邊買進大概16億美元的科技氣熊
所以有可能是由於科技巨頭在最近的發揮
就跟臺股一樣
臺股你只要拉臺積電聯發客
一不小心就會創下一點新高
這很容易的
可是你說臺股假設今年年底上五萬點
我還是很樂觀的
你覺得大多數今年五月份六月份高點見到的股票
你覺得年底會創新高嗎
你覺得臺積電創新高的時候
國巨能不能收復九成的跌幅
那都很大的挑戰對不對
所以我們才講說
現在其實如果行情重新迴流到上半年被遺忘的科技七雄身上
那就代表的指數過高衝高速度就會很快
但是體感上就不一定是這樣子
現在換算下來
現在機構投資人
把資金集中到亞馬遜
Alphabet Meta 微軟
這些股票當中的速度
在過去兩週是非常明顯的
所以我們必須從行前來做進一步推敲
因為整個上半年我們很清楚
資金幾乎就圍繞在AI基礎建設周邊
都認為花錢的人不值得投資
但是賣產值的人值得投資
所以當時都是AI基礎周邊
像是AI基礎建設
AI資料中心
甚至國防原物料
那反而是科技七雄
在上半年是大幅的跑速給大盤
那能否藉由這一次的輪動
剛才漲的都是一些大型全資股
有的是費辦
有的是納指
藉由這些全資股的衝高
來帶動新一輪的行情
值得留意
因為美歐股市這一波漲勢
我們過去提過
一直都不是很平均
我們把半導體的ETF
SMH
今年累積到現在為止
應該說從三月份
當時每一站是到現在
大概漲了150%
科技七雄才漲多少
45%
那你說
那七雄是不是真的很落後
其實標普等權表現
RSP也漲幅只有20%
這就說明
雖然七雄是比半導體還要弱一點
可是如果你連AI都沾不上邊
AI跟半導體
非相關股票報酬
更是遠遠在落後
所以這就可以瞭解說市場的顯著分化
那如果我們細看
今年的七巨頭
如果我們以Fang來看好了
真正亮麗的
基本上也是半導體和大型股
美光今年漲了265%
輝達漲了21%
蘋果漲了24%
Alphabet上漲13%
Meta12%
接下來就落後大盤了
Amazon漲11%
微軟今年
即便這兩天彈幅很明顯
今年也不過漲3.7
因為今年年初是在跌太多
Panel Tier上漲3%
博通漲4.7%
所以我可以瞭解說
在金牙股當中
並不是大部分的科技股都在創下新高
主要就是來自於上半年是由硬體股來推
但是現在短期內
硬體股行情沒有非常明顯的板塊輪動以後
靠少數個股來往上拉
這個時候就達到順勢突破的效果了
不過至少可以承認
行情永遠都圍繞在AI題材裡頭
你不管買到軟體股硬體股
只要跟AI
你還是有很高的幾率能夠跑贏大盤
人工智慧現在最大投資風險
已經不是AI股票太多了
因為所有資產都已經變成了
AI交易的一部分
我們根據彭博的數據
AI基礎建設相關公司
現在佔標普500的總市值
大概已經來到40%
三家晶片公司就佔新興市場指數
超過四分之一
今年AI相關企業發行的投資等級在
已經接近全球的一半
創投資金有87%都是AI創新企業
所以你只要做非AI相關的
你幾乎也拿不到錢了
這也是為什麼大型退休基金
現在很難去重新計算
自己到底壓了多少AI
如果我們把這些所有的
比如說阿發貝
Amazon Meta
Netflix
甚至連特斯拉
都把它納入到廣義的科技股
現在佔整個標普白指數
大概已經51%了
不管你怎麼投
你幾乎都會投到AI
所以AI泡沫破滅
你也很難能夠成功的規避
這個就是主導全球的
新一輪的資金走向
那現在什麼也都要AI
AI手機 AI電腦 AI助理 AI投資 AI金融
彷彿整個市場上
你產品名字如果沒有一個AI
你就已經輸在起跑點了
所以從這樣的一個角度來做思考
你會發現信用市場表面比較平靜
但底下其實藏著非常龐大的AI鉅債
這個就是後續要留意的
你看OpenAI現在已經宣佈
打算明年再來進行IPO了
那軟銀的壓力就越來越大了
軟銀最近孫正義為了要
持續能夠有新一輪的資金能夠湧入
大幅提高取債規模
最新一輪的已經承諾
或者正在洽談的新增債務
大概是209億美元
其中過去以ARM的股票擔保貸款額多
再增加50億美元
目的是什麼
如果今年IPO
它就可以順勢的出脫一點股票
那到時候資本就能夠有效的回饋
那現在OpenAI今年沒有要上市
所以整個資金就相對來的更為緊湊
那我們要知道
現在其實軟銀所發行的債券
已經接近垃圾債等級
這說明軟銀的擴張速度
其實是非常非常快的
很多人
就我們講說背後很多
不管是避險基金
還是投資公司
他可能就是單押在某一檔AI成分股上
然後對賭他能夠成功
所以本身大家都冒著極大的風險
甲骨文他就是另外一個例子
甲骨文最近在新墨西哥州
總投資規模1650億美元的木星計劃
最新宣佈可能要延後
主要是去年
有180億美元的貸款啟動建設
結果現在近期的相關貸款
每億美元的面額
只跌到0.89到0.91塊
明顯低於正常優質債券
接近面額的水準
這一座資亞中心很大
1400英畝
它之前是跟甲骨文跟OpenAI
高達3000億美元
算力合約的重要基地
結果現在取債速度太快
信用體質快速的轉落
結果延後了
那你如果說只是由於短期內蓋不出來
最後把它蓋出來那還好
重點是算力生不出來
那你錢要怎麼收回來呢
我們看甲骨文的負債
24年底大概就800億
後來總負債到現在
今年年底已經來到1560億
短短兩年就已經翻倍了
再看它的KPX
資本支出也是進入到爆發式成長
以前單季的資本支出大概就是20多億美元
現在AI資料中心大舉擴建
25年突破50億
100億
到今年8月份
單季就280億了
所以它的速度也沒有任何減緩的跡象
那麼一旦引起反彈
壓力就來了
所以現在資料中心也面臨地方的反彈和工程延誤
這個木星計劃
就甲骨文的主要的AI建設計劃
天然氣款正在遭受到顯著的阻擋
那麼有部分銀行團已經開始陸續退出
當地民調
有65%居民是反對大型資料中心開發
這是阿布奎基日報
就是當地的報紙
就是那個絕命毒師住的地方
那與此同時
我們也知道說
這背後的融資結構越來越大
整個資料中心
現在就靠著180億美元的專案融資貸款支撐
其他還包含著165億美元的工業收益債券
那如果有人先撤資
那這個資料中心到底蓋不蓋得完呢
還是會有人接手
這就是非常非常大的挑戰
那我們講說
現在美國的AI企業
就是面臨這樣的一個風險
就是我們都清楚知道
這一輪AI最需要檢視的
AI股票其實已經沒有想象中這麼貴了
因為估值已經變低了
因為獲利追上來了
但是AI正在滲透整個資本市場
那大量的人獲得資金以後
就去大舉發債
然後包括私募創投資金
就大量的去壓住AI
連原本拿來風險
分散風險這些基礎建設
或者信用市場
你買債券其實也是對賭AI
你買股票也是對賭AI
你買指數也是對賭AI
你把資金拿去給退收基金
他也是買AI
大家都一樣
那有時候順風的時候
大家看結果
你只要給出好的產品
你只要給出更好的模型
大家就叫好
那現在你已經推出一陣子了
那AGI時代還沒有全面到來
那大家就開始要求
你這算力的回本速度
到底有能夠多快
所以反正順風的時候
大家看的是結果
但到逆風的時候
就開始產生利益衝突了
那有銀行團就先跑了
那有資料中心這麼大
那180億的資料中心突然就停擺了
遊戲規則就突然不同了
過去沒有人在意的那個記錄
就重新被拿出來檢視
沒有啊
你那個時候跟我承諾
幾月幾號要蓋好
現在你沒蓋好
所以我也不用負擔相對應的責任
這個就是一系列的衝擊
順風的時候
大家看的是結果
逆風的時候就開始挑刺
有這樣的感覺
我最近才看到一條新聞
昨天網友傳給我的
他們現在都很喜歡標註訊息給我
他講的是最近核庫金的訊息
我們知道最近財政部
要推動核庫第一兆豐華南
四家公股投信診病
預估到今年年底完成
結果現在核庫投信
爆出內控的爭議
這個是靖州刊的獨家
根據吹哨者的說法
今年6月
人資主管在處理
診病所需的員工薪資
和獎金資料的時候
疑似把機密檔案上傳到雲端
並且運用AI來運算
然後因為觸發了治安系統
後來母公司就調查並離職
那最後又意外發現
這才是主軸
發現這個王投資長
合庫的王投資長
中長期使用公司電腦瀏覽
日本的拍賣網站
搜尋成人影片的女優
寫真以及女優的相關商品
累積瀏覽記錄超過萬筆
上述內容主要來自於
吹哨者的指控
還跟正式調查結果要有所區分
然後相關的瀏覽行為
大部分是集中在中午12點到下午4點
那吹哨者就明顯指控
說他的辦公桌上放有多張
帶有簽名 唇印 裸露的女優卡片
那這個事件就變成從上班摸魚
變成到公司治理 資訊安全
然後現在已經檢舉到金管會了
那目前的指控是這樣
就是因為主要是中午12點和4點
大量密集的去看A片
所以剛好是臺股殺尾盤
還有歐洲股市開盤
準備迎接美國股市盤前交易的關鍵時刻
王身為投資長
沒有帶領好下屬好好看盤
操盤已經踩到公司紅線
你不覺得看完這個新聞很扯嗎
因為這個新聞
我是找了一個沒有露臉的
他網路上每一張圖片都露臉
殺人都會打碼
看A片卻沒打碼
難道是因為他喜歡看無碼的嗎
所以這肯定得罪人
我講的就是順風的時候
還沒有鬥爭之前
這精精病還沒有出現之前
大家就得過且過
那開始要病之後
你看看雙方的鬥爭就開始了
這你幾家公股行庫
你感覺稍微要做一點什麼大事
就開始瘋狂連環出發
這不是又有人在整他嗎
我是不太那個欣賞
把人家照片拿出來
又不是什麼滔天大醉
把人家弄涉死
不過我們還是要做社會研究
你說他本來是要查AI
查錯變查AV
對啊有什麼問題嗎
而且聖人模式才不容易追高
這時候大腦才冷靜
我們講實在的
你如果是績效好
那看AV又怎麼樣
他又不是正大光明
他把聲音放出來
然後到處大家
他可能就私底下
偶爾不小心點到這樣子
這有人要你的位置
所以我們才講說
這個AI行情好的時候
你查AV我都拿你當AI
能賺錢都行
當AI行情不好
要清算
有人要鬥爭你的時候
你看AV都天理不容
連照片都不幫你
所以我們才講說
這個衝擊越來越大
當然
當然你說這一次因為我們叫公股投信要四合一整並
那又有爆料人
然後在這個時間點
然後年底又快到了
所以我們才講說順豐的時候績效
它可以掩蓋出很多的雜音
那金控業你說有多震驚嗎
逆風或者權力重整的時候
反而馬上就變成內控問題
變成紀律問題
變成職場爭議
已經上升到金管會了
什麼年代了
這種東西當然是用手機偷偷看
正常也不會到電腦看
我以前不理解
為什麼每次公司早上9點鐘
廁所就擠滿人
我想說股市交易很興盛
看起來我錯估了
好噁心
社會死亡
對於你這個大膽的想法
臺灣有一套完整的刑法
法官有一套客觀的看法
刑警有一手精準的槍法
木匠有一套高超的技法
棺材有花裡胡哨的造法
焚屍有一百多種的辦法
賓館有一套隆重的藏法
所納有一套熟練的吹法
墓地有一個良好的埋法
非洲有一套歡樂的跳法
黑人有一套專業的抬法
墳草有各式各樣的長法
盜墓賊有一套完整的盜法
音書有一首實用的盜法
地獄有十分專業的判法
我們重新組織一下語法
說起那份十分大膽的想法
好惡心好惡心
好不管怎麼說
我個人的看法是
但是有時候我們在順風的時候
市場上就不會去懷疑
現在稍微遇到一點逆風
斤斤計較
現在甲骨的確面臨相當大的挑戰
8點55分
我們今天重點是要往下聊
來看一下在其中選舉的衝擊
其實我們都很清楚知道
現在川普唯一能夠拿得出良好政績的
可能就是股票市場了
因為正常來講
我們過去提過在其中選舉之前
股票市場有適度賣壓是很正常的
因為政策充滿著極大的不確定性
白宮我們都清楚知道
現在的民調應該是很有高的幾率
你來嘲笑也大
共和黨現在要同時掌握白宮參眾議院的可能性幾乎是零
那現在就看起來能不能守住眾議院
那真正能夠同時在兩院不退反進的案例也非常少了
98年的克林頓
911事件的小布希勉強還撐過去
川普以前也吃過這個虧
18年他當時第一次任期的期中選舉
共和黨就一次丟掉了41個眾議院席次
直接失去了眾議院的控制權
雖然當時參議院還反而增加兩席
但這一次的確挑戰更大
我們看知道Polling Market目前的賭盤
參眾議院兩院看起來翻盤的可能性都很高
交易者目前給予民主黨拿下參議院
大概是61%的隱含幾率
眾議院是92%
其中民主黨同時控制參眾兩院的交易幾率是61%
相對之下
共和黨首座參議院
民主黨拿下眾議院的31%
還是有比較明顯的弱差
那另外一方面
在最新的川普民調當中
從多家民調來進行總體彙整
川普總體支持率大概是38%
不支持率
上個禮拜又創高了
來到59%
如果我們看各家民調
其實不管是偏左媒偏右媒
還是單純看路特
EPSO相關的民調
大概整體淨負支持率
就是支持減掉負支持的
或者說支持減掉不支持的比例
剩下來的負值
大概都是-18到-25之間
這個比例落差
其實還是相對來的比較大
這也使得一個跡象
照理來講
市場上的不確定性應該會因此而加大
所以美國股市本輪的創高
就沒有那種太多的政治上的擔憂
利空形成在其中
當然由於三大指數四大指數
它也算是盤整了一段時間
雖然大家股價都沒創高
其實沒創高本身已經算利空了
因為獲利還在持續往上走
又不是獲利表現平平
股價沒有波動
獲利正在以金人的速度往上走
沒有大幅創高
其實就已經算跌了
這是我們過去的立場
只要獲利還在往上走
股價不漲
本益比就會快速的下滑
所以這一次我們要更進一步觀察
也許在政治領域
能夠進一步在估值回調的空間
今年大概已經回調兩次了
一次是三四月
另外一次就是七八月
現在美國期中選舉還沒有投
不過在選後的政策邊緣還是很大
還是有機會
我認為如果要等回調
我覺得還是有機會的
今年7月才等到一次
通常是三到四個月
會迎來一次比較大的一個回調
那如果你是以週期佈局來看的話
也不會說錯過了一次機會
就再也買不到了
你可以現在少量佈局
等到下一次再做一次
比較大的一個回調
來做佈局也是OK的
我們根據民主黨
現在在11月的期中選舉國會佈局
反而呈現了很有趣的局面
這期中選舉都還沒有投
眾議院的監督委員會
民主黨首席議員
就已經開始決定
委員會在眾議院取得多數以後
從今年下半年開始
要大幅針對川普本人
家族成員
商業夥伴
和富豪盟友的調查
什麼意思
準備要清算
其中其中都還沒投
民主黨已經假設
眾議院能夠大勝
相關的委員會的籌備計劃
正在細節探索當中
包括川普的長子小唐納
過去他的確取得了很多政府合約
看起來現在是合規的
不過眾議院就是把你調來停診
你不調來藐視國會
所以我們看到一系列的文件調閱
和傳票權利
可能會大幅的影響到
在整個27年28年
川普的執政效果
另外一方面我們也知道
川普過去曾經想要限制郵寄投票
但是最高法院這次踩剎車了
不代表說完全是合法的
但是這一次期中選舉
是很明顯規定
不能夠遭受到司法的阻擋
原因就來自於
因為再過兩個月就要投票了
那現在其實已經有人開始投票了
那如果現在才規定說要踩剎車
那今年的選舉一定會大亂
所以最高法院目前是決定
期中選舉的規則暫時不改動
所以未來一段時間
我們知道川普想要限制郵寄投票的做法
在期中選舉是無法發揮他的一個效力的
這是另外一層我們看到的實質跡象
那你說共和黨難道沒有任何的優勢嗎
共和黨其中一個最大優勢
就是錢很多
現在共和黨所擁有的政治現金
是民主黨的好幾倍
我們看到各大的科技巨頭
陸續表態了
從整個25年到26年的選舉週期
整體來說
其中選舉大部分
有三分之一都是集中在
前20名的超級金組
其中20人當中
有16人都把主要資金
押向共和黨陣營
科技巨頭大幅的親共
親共和黨
目的就是相信
共和黨在科技議題
尤其是AI一體當中
相對於民主黨更為友善
所以大量資金開始湧入以後
至少我們知道
AI派 科技派 加密貨幣派
似乎已經默默站隊了
民主黨其實也獲得部分資金
不過從總體資金量而言
共和黨是有背負著相當大的
AI監管放鬆的壓力
來向選民 來向市場
來進行傳送市場的概況
當然我們都會很清楚知道
這些問題是否能夠足以扭轉
當前的眾議院選情
其實難度是很高的
原因很簡單
因為根本還是物價的上漲問題
美國經濟現在出現最大的矛盾
就是失業率4.1%
消費還是很強勁
但是家庭的淨資產
第二季已經達到186兆美元
一般家庭的生活壓力
就在持續上升當中
所以整個8月份的消費者物價指數
如果是從這樣的一個速度上行的話
基本上是不會有太大的一個改變的
加上我們也清楚知道
現在美國的AI基礎建設
雖然各大巨頭花了這麼多錢
希望你能夠幫助我們能夠通過
可是各地都出現了
比較明顯的地方反彈
地方政府和居民不想讓他蓋
那民主黨又處處卡關
而且民主黨州
我們看到的蘭州
又大量的延後
資料中心的新建計劃
採取更多的監管措施
最後AI到頭來
你說真的會由於
給予川普或者共和黨足夠的資金
中央政府就能夠幫你處理這件事情嗎
也許到年底以後
這個AI派就要跟民主黨重新和解了
這個是目前看起來
至少能夠看到的立場
資料中心的延後
一個是像甲骨文
錢的問題
一個就是選民的反制
一下選民喊不要
一下民主黨又喊停
不要停不要停
怎麼搞
所以這個就是現在整個全美市場當中
對於AI在下半年比較大的變數
大家反而不是很擔心川普政治受到約束
那個反而OK
重點是怕民主黨控制國會
兩院以後
那會不會未來的AI資料中心
會一個接著一個停擺呢
這個就是更大的估值回調理由
也給投資朋友做一些觀察
所以雖然現在美股股市在創高
我們的結論第一個
少數個股正在衝高
拉全職股
就跟臺股現在一樣
上漲800點
收在48,520點
林發哥直接跳高這樣上去
從全職股的拉動
它就足以帶動指數往上衝了
可是到年底5萬點了
你覺得你在五六月份
套高的股票解得了套嗎
這就是一個挑戰
那第二個觀察重點
還是來自於
現在AI行情走到現在
我們都很清楚知道
在資料中心的興建
或者在融資的過程當中
它已經形成了部分的制約
這些都是讓未來
估值仍然有回調的理由
不要覺得股票市場
上漲一次就會永遠上漲
我們在這麼多年的河流途當中
就算是AI行情
它都會有情緒低迷的時候
最後我們也看得出來
川普現在已經算是
所有招數都已經使出了
儘可能在期中選舉之前
來收攏戰線
包括關稅戰
包括川習會
各項議題
也許在本週釋出以後
會是對於市場的一大利多
那三層力量互相角力
形成今年年底的跡象
給投資朋友做些參考
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上半半
早晨財經四點多再相見
祝各位投資朋友開盤順利
超盤愉快